my advice to young people's you never
want to do something on the spur of the
moment you don't want to jump too
quickly that doesn't mean you should sit
around and waste your whole life and
never realize when something's not going
to happen or when the opportunities not
going to be presented but every time I
thought about leaving Solomon I stopped
stopped and said you know I'm learning a
lot and even though I might have been
able to make more money elsewhere it was
a great firm they were scrupulously
honest phenomenally competent worked
very hard very nice to me and I always
decided to stay I don't think I ever
seriously other than maybe a little
walter mitty dream now and then I think
of a seriously ever thought of leaving
and it turned out to be great i can say
nothing but good things about them even
when them firing it was the right thing
when you jump off that cliff and your
only intention is to fly before you hit
the bottom you're gonna animate all your
vital resources to learn how to fly on
the way down and that's why you have to
jump you know there's a different type
of response to that clip that a lot of
people most people experience and that
is they stare down that Cliff their
entire lives until they're like 40 45 50
and the guy they call this midlife
crisis this is when you've committed to
all of the trappings notice that we're
trapping trappings trash of the world
now you got a family you've got a
business you got a career you got a boss
you got casas they can't jump dude
because you're too trapped by the
trappings of the world now my book I say
you still joke but anyway the point is
but if you stand there you just keep
looking down that get into that chasm
and it begins you know you reach the
edge of that cliff when you're 25 years
old guess what you're going to live with
for the next 25 years distress
kills you because you didn't jump
there's that part of you that's always
tapping you hey dude I told you to jump
20 years ago you still didn't jump did
you how do you feel about yourself well
I've got a hundred thousand dollars in
my bank account man who gives us my
wife's hot that gives us I got children
to take care who gives it you should
have jumped when I told you to jump and
now you gotta live with it my intention
with this video was just read
understanding not fighting I want you to
see that it's not one point of view or
the other you can pull and learn from
folks especially the one that you don't
immediately resonate with embrace the
genius of the end